anger over the deadly police shooting of
an unarmed black man in Sacramento is
intensifying hundreds of protestors
block fans from entering a Sacramento
Kings basketball game last night
they also temporarily shut down a public
meeting with city leaders it was held to
discuss Stephon Clarke's death ten days
ago John Blackstone is outside City Hall
with the latest on this story John good
morning good morning well the mayor was
forced to end the meeting early out of
safety concerns when it turned into a
shouting match the police department
here has invited the California
Department of Justice to oversee its
investigation into Clark's shooting
death but that appears to have done
little to ease the city's tensions
Savanti Clark LED protesters in a chant
of his brother Stefan's name just
minutes into the Sacramento City
Council's public meeting about the 22
year-olds shooting death on March 18th
like many here he called for an end to
police violence upon Clark was shot at
20 times in his grandmother's backyard
after police mistook the cell phone he
was holding for a gun does this look as
you point this to our council does this
look like a gun meetings overflow crowd
marched to the NBA arena where the
Sacramento Kings were playing they
blocked all entrances for the second
time in less than a week I think we're
gonna grow from this event and that's
what matters
Sacramento Police Chief Daniel Han says
his department is continuing its own
investigation into the shooting and
looking into whether officers acted
improperly when they muted the audio on
their body cams
shortly after shooting Clark
he says the department does have a
policy where officers are allowed to
mute their cameras in certain situations
still regardless of whether they work
within policy or not if you're already
somebody in our community that didn't
trust the police department you're
probably gonna think well there's
something shady about what they're doing
and that hurts us right or wrong muting
it didn't help this situation it did not
correct more body cam videos are set to
be released those were shot by officers
who arrived at the scene after the
shooting now it's unclear when those
will be released or whether they will
contain the audio that was muted on the
other cameras meanwhile black lives
matter has announced that they are
planning protests every day through
Clark's funeral which is set for
Thursday
Nora married John thank you so much